s'affirme donc avoir repoussé une
offensive de grande envergure menés par
les troubles ukrainiennes dans le Dombas
mais pour l'instant je vous le disais
Kiev n'a pas commenté ces annonces alors
est-ce le début de la contre-offensive
ukrainienne tant attendue à Kiev on
retrouve Gulliver crack
c'est la même question que se pose je
pense ce matin les Ukrainiens on se
réveillant à ses nouvelles venons en
partie de ces annonces faites par la
Russie comme quoi il y aurait eu une
échec d'une tentative de pousser dans le
sud de la région de Thonet que mes
accompagnés aussi d'informations sur des
chaînes télégram russes qui sont certes
pro-guerre pro Poutine mais un peu plus
attaché à dire la vérité sur ce qui se
passe sur le terrain où l'image un peu
plus mixte des succès pour les rues sont
détruisant de l'équipement notamment
américain que les Ukrainiens utilisaient
mais aussi certains endroits les
Ukrainiens qui auraient poussé
l'Institut pour les études de la guerre
à Washington dit qu'il n'est pas en ce
moment en mesure de confirmer ces
informations et côté officiel en Ukrain
c'est vraiment silence radio le mot
d'ordre qui a été d'ailleurs répété dans
une vidéo qu'ils ont publié hier et
vraiment de garder le silence savais pas
commenter de ne pas donner
d'informations qui pourraient dévoiler
les plans de l'Ukraine quant à cette
contre-offensive